when most people think of credit cards
they think of debt high interest rates
and predatory lending this is not
surprising when you consider that on
average americans carry 6194
worth of credit card debt so from their
perspective credit cards have always
been this sort of boogeyman that results
in them overextending themselves and
then paying the price for years but
contrary to what dave ramsey says credit
cards don't have to be a bad thing most
credit cards offer cash back rewards
flexible return policies fraud
protection the ability to build your
credit score and so much more
and if you use these cards correctly you
can actually profit quite a bit
this is especially true with american
express cards which operate on a
fundamentally different basis to
traditional credit cards many amex cards
don't even allow you to carry a balance
meaning that you have to pay off your
entire balance every month this is
because charging stupid high interest
rates is not amex's top priority instead
amex makes most of their money from
charging merchants higher fees and
charging credit card holders an annual
fee when applying for credit cards you
may have seen credit cards with fees and
hundreds of dollars but those are just
the cards that are offered to us
peasants the highest tier most exclusive
mx card is called the centurion card
also known as the black card this card
is invite only and is usually offered to
the biggest businessman and celebrities
in the world
but just because you're invited doesn't
mean you get the card you actually have
to pay a ten thousand dollar initiation
fee along with five thousand dollars
every year that you have the card but
despite this insanely high fee the amex
black is by far the most sought after
card in the world so why are people
willing to pay so much for a piece of
plastic or i guess metal and what do you
even get from owning this elite card
before we get into the perks of the card
itself i think we should take a look at
the history of the card because it's
quite unique it's not like amex just had
an idea to create the super elite card
that came along with first class
services rather the origin of the black
card can actually be traced back to
urban legends it all started in may of
1988 when the wall street journal ran a
story theorizing the existence of an
exclusive black card the publication
didn't make their sources clear but
apparently amex had been experimenting
with a vip card that was only offered to
their wealthiest and most trustworthy
clients according to the journal less
than a thousand customers were offered
this card and it was only available for
a mere four years before mx canceled the
program when the card was available
though the perks were really just up to
your imagination did you forget to book
a reservation at a fancy restaurant well
just call amex and they'll take care of
it did you forget your jacket at your
hotel room well just call amex and
they'll take care of it did you get lost
in the desert well you know the drill
just call amex and they'll take care of
it as you can see the amex black wasn't
the card with set in stone benefits
it's not like you get 8 back on gas and
10 back on groceries and 15 back on
flights in fact you couldn't even be
charged on the card directly rather
charges would be routed to your mx
platinum gold or green accounts so the
card more or less just gave you the
ability to call amex and put in requests
but all of this was just the wall street
journal's theories and speculation the
only proof they had in support of the
black card even existing was a statement
from an amex spokesman named lee
middleton lee confirmed the existence of
the black card and claimed that it was
only offered to customers with a
substantial banking relationship with
amex lee went on to claim that the
program was indeed cancelled because it
just wasn't worth keeping it up lee
wrapped up his statement by suggesting
that the new mx platinum card offered 95
of the services that the black card did
so there was no reason to continue
offering the black despite this final
statement many wall street journal
readers wanted the black card anyway and
over the next several years we saw more
and more stories covering the alleged
perks of this card soon enough the black
card became an urban legend amongst
finance and business nerds but the
ironic part is that the card likely
never even existed but wait a minute
didn't the spokesman basically confirm
all of the wall street journal
speculation well yes he did but there's
also evidence that he was lying you see
it in 1999 mx would actually launch the
centurion card and the director of amex
europe doug smith would come clean about
it doug said quote there had been rumors
going around that we had this ultra
exclusive black card for elite customers
it wasn't true but we decided to
capitalize on the idea anyway so it
looks like lee was just leaning into
speculation to create hype for the
company and a story from jerry seinfeld
would further verify this if you're not
familiar with jerry he's an extremely
famous comedian who was the face of amex
in the early 1990s and during one of his
shoots a crew member would ask jerry if
he had a black card unfamiliar with
their card jerry would ask what is the
black card the crew member would reply
that it was a super exclusive card that
was only issued to three people in the
world
apparently one was given to the sultan
of brunei one was given to the president
of amex and the crew member was
speculating that the third one was given
to jerry jerry obviously didn't have one
so he would put this rumor to rest but
as you would guess he was quite curious
so he called the president of mx the
next day to ask about the mx black and
here's what the president replied
it's just a rumor it doesn't exist but
you know what it's not a bad idea so it
looks like lee was indeed just hyping up
the company but amex would eventually
answer these urban legends by launching
the card for real
[Music]
now that the mx black is actually a real
thing it comes with a slew of defined
benefits starting with elite status at
hospitality brands the card comes with
isg platinum elite hilton honors diamond
marriott bon voy gold and roules and
chateau 5c
in terms of travel you get delta
skymal's platinum medallion status which
includes priority waitlisting priority
checking and boarding it and courtesy
upgrades if you have this card though
waiting at the airport probably wouldn't
be that bad anyways because you get
access to the global lounge collection
this includes lounges that are branded
centuriana mx priority pass escape delta
sky club plaza premium and aerospace you
also get an invitation to hertz's
platinum status and avis presidents club
aside from travel benefits you get a
bunch of retail benefits as well for
example you get to be a part of the
centurion shopping program and you also
get one of the fx membership points on
purchases over five thousand dollars but
honestly none of these perks are really
that special the mx platinum card has
most of the same perks and has better
rewards as well for example the amex
platinum offers 5x membership points on
flights and prepaid hotels now it's not
like the amex platinum is cheap given
that it costs 695 dollars per year but
it's just a fraction of the cost of the
mx black and it comes with all of the
same tangible benefits so if you're just
looking to turn credit cards and earn
rewards there's absolutely no reason to
get the black the only reason to get the
black is if you're looking for vip
service and this is where the black
really shines and i think the best way
to really understand the caliber of
their vip service is by simply looking
at stories take chinese billionaire lou
you can for example
lou is an avid art collector and often
buys paintings that are worth tens of
millions if not over a hundred million
but instead of writing a check or
completing a wire transfer to buy these
paintings lu likes to put it on his amex
card one time he put a 36 million tea
cup from the ming dynasty onto his amex
but by far his most outrageous credit
card purchase was a 170 million dollar
painting this purchase alone would have
earned him a 170 million mx membership
points depending on how he redeemed
these points he could get 1.7 million to
3.4 million worth of rewards thanks to
his purchase not to mention it amex
allowed him to bypass chinese transfer
laws you see china does not allow its
citizens to transfer more than fifty
thousand dollars out of their country in
any given year but since lou charged it
on a credit card he definitely wasn't
transferring any money out of china he
was just paying off his credit card i
suspect that the ccp wasn't that happy
to hear about this purchase aside from
approving crazy large purchases amex
also bends to basically any customer
desire as long as it's not illegal of
course you could say they live by the
motto we shall never deny a guest even
the most ridiculous request and believe
me they get some ridiculous requests for
example this one amex black client was
staying on a private island when they
ran out of ice cubes instead of getting
more eyes from their beach house or just
drinking the rest of their drink without
ice the client decided to call amex and
ask for ice and sure enough amex ended
up playing out a bag of ice declined on
a helicopter this other client asked
amex to deliver flowers to eight
girlfriends in four different states and
three different countries and mx of
course ended up doing it while there are
some crazy stories of people abusing the
system like this the vast majority of
centurion customers don't actually make
such requests more times than not they
just want their entire travel experience
to be taken care of and streamlined
these guys don't want to think about
booking flights and hotels and making
restaurant reservations and travel
arrangements and so on they like the
convenience of calling amex and telling
them where they want to go and what they
want to do and have mx take care of the
rest and the given that many of these
guys are extremely frequent travelers so
the service is invaluable to them
hearing all of that i'm sure that
getting an amex and tyrion card is
likely a goal for some of you ambitious
souls out there so how exactly do you go
about getting the black card well at
first glance it might seem like you have
to be a billionaire or celebrity but
this is actually not true
really it just comes down to spending a
lot of money on mx cards no one really
knows what the threshold is for mx to
consider you some estimates say that you
have to spend 250 000 per year while
others say that you have to spend a
million dollars per year to be honest i
don't think there is a threshold per se
and each approval is likely given on a
case-by-case basis for example if you
have some sort of notoriety from being
an actor or singer or something like
that you can probably get approved with
lower spend it because giving you the
card would likely give amex some
exposure as well
but if you're a background businessman
that owns a couple of car dealerships or
something you probably have to have much
higher spend to get an invitation
regardless of your status though if you
consistently spend a boatload of money
as in half a million dollars per year or
more on their cards chances are you'll
get an invitation something to keep in
mind though is that if you're just
trying to get the card for status or
clout the card is probably not for you
the true purpose of the card is to get
valuable concierge services and if these
services don't really apply to you
you're just burning money on the annual
fee for a bit of attention not to
mention it this attention is not exactly
a type of attention that you want sure
it might be cool amongst your friends
and family and business acquaintances
who will be impressed and happy for you
but whipping out such a card at walmart
is likely not the best idea so just make
sure you're getting the card for the
right reasons but that's just what i
think would you guys get us in touring
card comment that down below
also drop a like if you're a fan of
using credit cards the right way and of
course consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]